tik-tok has basically exploded out of
nowhere over the last year to become one
of the most downloaded apps in the world
it's a place where videos can go viral
in minutes and new influencers there
being discovered every single day I just
downloaded the app on my phone and my
kids have been helping me make fun
videos but you know as business owners
and entrepreneurs how are we supposed to
use this platform to market if you're
going to be spending your time on social
media you want it to be effective and
ultimately lead to customers and clients
it's not just an app that kids are
hanging out on it is actually an app
that hosts one of the best discover
abilities for your business and brand
you know overnight success is just a
myth but with an app like tick tock
exposure to your next client is closer
than you think
so in this episode i sat down with Jane
she's an 18 year old CEO of multiple
brands and she breaks down what's
working right now on tic toc and how you
and I as business owners can leverage
this emerging platform to grow our
business and our brand in 2020 and
beyond
the number one podcast we're growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm your host Heather torres and i'm
shawn Cannell and we're from think media
and if this is your first time listening
we are fired up you're here this show is
dedicated to helping you learn how to
get your content notice and the latest
money-making strategies that are working
right now online so whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel or you're
ready to maximize video across all of
social media then this podcast is for
you well thanks Jade for being on the
think marketing podcast today how are
you I'm doing so good Heather thanks for
having me I'm so excited yes I I think
for me I'm most excited to interview you
because you in your business career have
so much experience shoved into such a
short amount of time and I'm just really
excited to bring you to the think
marketing podcast community and to grow
this video live this year so are you
ready to jump into some questions Jade
oh my gosh jump right in I'm ready to
jump into this
Poole of what what am I saying we got it
we got it okay so uh Jade you are a
young entrepreneur so walk me through
how did you get here
like how did you get to where you are
right now in business good question man
when I was nine years old that's where
my journey started I didn't not actually
I did have a lemonade stand so gary
vaynerchuck i am trying to copy your
bread and really just take over the
world but long story short my movie star
came from making doll videos on YouTube
so before YouTube was like SEO driven
and all the fun algorithm stuff I was a
kid at making doll videos you can
literally search me it's like kiddie
films eight on YouTube I had like a few
videos go like two at the time was a lot
of views there's like a hundred thousand
views which now like videos go for like
millions of views but that was still a
lot at my time and I remember that's
when I got started just making videos
for fun I remember my real like business
start came after like 10 or 11 years old
I started to realize I could sell dolls
for money because I was like just you
know wanting to get some coin and I used
my YouTube to market my dolls so I made
films to market my eBay listing of these
kind of vintage dolls so when I was like
around 12 or 11 I would say I'm just
entering fifth grade and I was having my
little ecommerce store my little YouTube
channel and most importantly I was able
to generate I think five thousand
dollars a month through my little stores
so it's been really fun journey and then
I think after that I did stop but I
stopped business just to be a kid for a
little bit then came right back at 16
I'm currently 18 years old and I do
similar things I make youtube videos I
also have a few businesses about social
media and that's what I've been working
on today I love it that's just amazing
how you know even as a young
entrepreneur you you caught vision of
what video could do right and how
marketing on video could really impact a
business and I love that you started
selling dolls I think it's amazing when
we start something that we don't really
go into for the purpose of making money
right isn't it great when you can just
start something that you're just
passionate about and then you move into
understanding oh I can monetize this and
really understanding how video works and
how you could grab an audience that is
interested in what you're selling
exactly like when you're out of pure
chené you have more patience with it and
you don't put expectations it's art and
that's how you can become literally
successful people kill themselves really
early just because they have high
expectations too early on yeah and you
are running multiple businesses right
now is that correct yeah I love your
passion for all the businesses that
you're doing and are you're using video
marketing for those businesses a hundred
percent I love that so um they're social
media right you know we've got Instagram
Twitter
we've got tick-tock we've got YouTube we
have Facebook all these social media
platforms from your perspective what are
some of the shifts that you're seeing in
marketing happening right now it as a
pertains to video and getting customers
through social platforms great question
I really think this biggest shift has to
be shorter attention spans which means
you can no longer post videos with cool
SEO and cool titles and thumbnails you
generally need to be good storyteller I
you can see this in two ways I see this
validated in tik-tok people have shorter
attention spans you're literally think
you'll think fifteen seconds you're not
even thinking ten minute YouTube videos
anymore right so you can see consumers
have shorter attention spans they want
fun bite-sized bite-sized pieces of
stories and the second thing I really
think is YouTube's algorithm and I
really do believe this is primarily you
know watch time and making sure people
stay as long as possible will say with
Instagram events but I really think that
you can no longer just leverage strategy
you just have to be a good storyteller
and storytelling comes from knowing how
to create a problem solution and making
it build you know character development
there's like it's weird because I mean
so I mean like the educational business
similar to you guys on the YouTube look
even in education you need to be good
speaker you can't just rely on SEO you
literally just can't so I really do
think now entertainment being funny
being a personality is crucial it's
impacts
so much like is as important as having
tried edgy and I really do think as that
shift happens you're gonna see people if
you don't do that you're gonna suffer
people have shorter attention spans
right and if you don't keep up with that
they're gonna forget yeah I completely
agree we're seeing that happening here
on YouTube we're seeing that happening
even on Instagram you know with the with
stories and even on Facebook with
stories and you're right being able to
tell a story within a short amount of
time is critical that like those
communication skills are everything
right I I'm so blown away by what you've
been able to accomplish by using you
know using short form video as it
pertains to tick tock and I want to talk
about that so as there are emerging
platforms like tick tock coming on the
scene how do business owners start to
use that I know you're using tick tock
right now to grow your business and so
what are you seeing give give me some of
the the pieces of tick tock and how you
can actually attract customers to your
business so tick tock is honestly weird
like I am I know I'm the m18 so I'm at
the age where I should fully understand
it I still don't fully understand it and
the reason I say that's just because
there's a little bit of misconception
tick tock is actually the worst platform
probably right now at least to convert
people it's the worst like if you look
at the platform do tick tock Heather do
you have tick tock yeah yes okay like
you can see there's literally no you
know an Instagram bio you or like an
YouTube description box you could add
the link to your website or whatever
tick tock of zero capabilities to link
aka drive traffic even if you look at
their bio page on Tech Talk there's no
like you can put like an Instagram bio
linked but that's it you can't drive
people to a site so do not think tick
tock as in perversions what people
really use it for is awareness and
multiple touch points so I really
recommend if a business I'll give my
brand for example so I run a company
called eat like we're a food box where
you can eat like your favorite celebrity
and we partner with athletes influencers
to create these food boxes so we did a
video campaign it was just a little
15-second a little like video of the
Food Box and me trying the snacks it's
super short I added a trendy song so the
song was key to help push it to
algorithm they got things like 50,000
views and in the comments people are
like what is this box what you get it
what you get I want to know more and I
link them to my site so as you can see
it's it's more for a brand awareness
like you know to measure exact
conversions right now the platform is
not built for that so you really have to
think about awareness touch points and
there's educating people about
product using music which I can go more
into but using those trendy songs to
really just get your your brand out off
the ground yeah I love that let's go
deeper into that because that is a big
piece of how tick tock works right it's
like viral music it doesn't necessarily
have to be music that's on the radio it
is its original songs
it's pieces of snippets of songs that
people are using to be creative around
that let's go deeper into that I like to
be very honest like tick tock is just a
bunch of people who are like thirst
traps which bass which basically means
like people who want attention for very
shallow needs so like you look at like I
don't know how peach helped you Jesus
podcasts Heather my friend Lee Jade
we're family friends around here that's
why I asked so we can make it tasteful
yes if you school to talk for five
minutes you're gonna get the idea most
of the popular creators are maybe more
provocative in a bit more let's just say
edgy so you're gonna see that the reason
why I brought it up is because you tick
tock is just solely meme culture so they
make fun of very edgy topics and edgy
songs so really the music you're right
has nothing to do with popular trends on
the radio it's about like can I make it
funny can I make it relevant can I make
it edgy so you're gonna see like I would
say if anyone's taking note it's like
the two main formats are like how to
pick a good song I would say the first
one is for the sole reason of people
right now it's like Tik Tok dancing is
huge you look at Charlie D'Amelio who's
an actual dancer but you can look at
other creators like Selena Cola she's a
friend of mine I did an interview with
her she's not a dancer like specifically
but she's able to make songs fun I think
there's something that's light-hearted
and entertaining so in reality if you're
trying to find a trendy song just go on
those larger pages and you can literally
pick those creators that are dancing to
it and you're more than likely gonna
pick a song that's like literally not on
the radio but like trending on Tik Tok
which is sometimes controlling the music
industry at this point the second form
of music I've seen is lyrics so I've
seen like people do memes whether it's
like the song and then there's a lyric
for example if the song is Baby by
Justin Bieber and you're just trying to
make a funny reference to like I don't
know your baby
crying and then you like do a lip sync
part of you saying baby to the part so
it's it's so there's two ways it's one's
lip-syncing what's dancing this
literally that's the only thing you need
to know like - looks pretty like it's
short it's simple it's entertaining and
if you pick songs for those two reasons
I'm sure you're good you're gonna get
more chances to be on the for you page
the for you page is the trending tab on
tick-tock yes I love thank you for that
I like that you described it two
different ways because as entrepreneurs
a lot of times we like to complicate
this right we like to look at these
platforms and say okay what's the
algorithm how do I beat this what you
know and really you really use you said
two really key things you said go on
larger pages and see what's already
working I do that on YouTube we do that
on Instagram the reason you want to do
that is because that allows you to see
like they've already put the work in
they're already the ones doing that full
time so might as well go and see what's
trending on their pages and second just
have fun I love how you said that this
is really just something to do
lip-synching dancing this is supreme
awareness to your brand and your
business it's not necessarily to get a
customer and convert right on the
platform it's to do things like build
know like and trust with your audience
um totally like if you go on to talk to
do a webinar I'm so sorry it's not the
platform for that but we have a lot of
business owners who are not on the
platform yet so well let's talk about
how they get started you're brand new -
tik-tok you open an account you do your
username give us three power tips that
people need to use when they're getting
started the first one that you said to
me before we started this interview was
to be authentic let's talk about that so
I really do think when I say be
authentic it's it's really just so it's
really weird I had this one I would say
its personality on tech talk where I try
food so you're gonna see like a whole
different personality on tik-tok and
it's weird cuz I did as a joke but
people in the comments were like trade
like this is not you I'm like how did
you guys know so I really do think as
simple as it sounds like you do not want
to overthink tik-tok and I really
you think if your natural passion is you
know coffee stick to coffee content make
funny Starbucks references if your
natural inclination is about e-commerce
and talking about business and stay that
Lane look do not do not do if you are
not a dancer do not try to make yourself
into a Charlie D'Amelio just because
people on tik-tok are at least a
demographic
a majority of it you're looking at is
like mmm I would say like you know
starting like teenager but like it's
getting older as well so they have a
little bit more of a inclination to
smell out like you know bs or things
that are not authentic to you so really
just make content that's you not because
it's trendy then goes back to like when
I would do YouTube for fun when I was
like 9 years old making doll videos like
dude out of passion and you don't have a
passion to talk has like really cool
explore page features so they have like
food like fashion how do you see that
okay I have yeah you go to the yeah it's
the Explorer page that's how I went
through it with my daughter just to see
what type of content I should be
creating because I am NOT a dancer I'm
not a singer but I want to be sharing my
personality on the platform so I went to
that page and that's how I saw the
different types of exhibits I don't
think these communities around those
different hashtags and trends and things
like that I think it's so fun because
it's trigger merrily you know picture so
they're export pages less I would say I
mean personable but it's great like I
for the first time I'm a Explorer peach
wasn't bombarded with Charlie de miel a
dancing it was food content it was stuff
that I like was researching upon so a
great start start with that find a
category like you're gonna like
literally just spend 10 minutes on Tech
Talk you're gonna understand how it
works it's very like you know you watch
a few videos with food you get it it's
like with the text the image the music
it's very simple yeah and I love that
and the tick tock algorithm really
starts to pick up on what type of
content you like to see because now I'll
go on my tick tock and it's like all the
same type of content that I like and
every now and then they'll throw in kind
of a random one and I just scroll past
that one but it's starting to really
understand what I would my interests are
based on the different types of content
I'm either posting or the type of
content that I'm consuming you know
what's so unique I just talked to a
friend about this she's like kind of
like one of the top craters on tech talk
we were talking about this and she's
saying like Jade Tech Talk think about
it is the only platform that actually
has immersive fullscreen videos they're
literally feeding you one video at a
time name another platform like that is
one like full vertical immersive piece
of content one at a time so it's like
really weird cuz like you have literally
no choice unless you're an explorer page
which I occasionally do you're mostly on
the for you page and they're literally
spooning you content because their
algorithm is that good so just imagine
that engagement in immersiveness of that
because there's no other problem like it
you know on YouTube you have like a few
videos listed on tick tock me just
literally have one at a time
yeah I love that and and so the first it
was be authentic the second one is to do
a lot of testing let's talk about that
how many times should you be posting
what type of content should be posting
tell me about testing mmm
honestly I really do think and like I
hope like the government's not listening
to me when I say this but I really do
think tick tock is categorizing me as
like Starbucks hacks girl like order
labeling I really do believe in the
algorithm they do that so they're
probably believe me as a food channel
because when I do other tic TOCs it's
not doing as well but in the beginning
when I was like just new I really do
think that's super important to post at
least three times a day like it stuns a
lot because they you know on YouTube
you're like once a week right
but tick tock three times a day beyond
that it's a little bit too aggressive
but at the start you know you're getting
you're gonna experiment that maybe the
food video the music the dancing and to
see which one works and like literally
what I would do is do that for like a
week then like a week later look at the
data see which is the most viral piece
of content you're gonna have like if you
do the math that's 21 pieces of content
in a week and you can see which one's
the number one and you can start to
niche down like I said but before that
don't even think about nation down just
try to diversify and make a ton of
content yeah and I like how you said you
didn't make three pieces of content and
then look at your you know numbers you
have to start it like on any platform
you have to be making constant or
consistent content to be able to
actually see what's working what's
resonating with your audience and tell
me it correct me if I'm wrong but the
audience you have on tik-tok may not be
the exact audience that you have on
YouTube or Instagram but you are growing
within a different audience segments is
that correct yeah but like here's the
thing so I definitely have a new
identity
like people on there they know me for
not shape the business girl but Jade but
long story short what's really unique is
you have to understand like at the end
of the day these are humans maybe they
know you as like this one place or just
a different demographic but what's super
important is like once they know your
name your brand well your product is
they're gonna talk about it to your
friends and then they're look you up
again on other social so you have to be
inclined that like at the end a day once
you are like marketing is all repetitive
so once you're up on the floor you page
you're consistent you know these are
people that can maybe buy your product
in the future maybe not right now
they're younger and a lot of people keep
saying like tick tock is like not my
niche but like in like about five years
they're gonna bout to be your number one
demographic with purchasing power so
just keep that in mind yeah it's it's
forward-thinking in your business not
thinking about what you're doing now but
it's really thinking about what you're
doing to plant yourself in the future I
love that so tip number one be authentic
on tick-tock don't be fake be real tip
number two post a lot do a/b testing see
what works and then go deeper in what's
working and the number three which to me
is like the number one of anything in
business which is take care of your fans
that are on tick-tock talk about
different ways that you can do that on
the platform it's pretty simple like
replying to comments
I remember when like the eat like box I
did like the video for the tick-tock
like you know people were asking work to
get the box it would be really bad of me
if I just didn't reply I replied
you know what's super cool to tick-tock
literally highlights and I think it
encourages people to reply if you reply
to a comment I don't know if you noticed
but it says like replied by the Creator
like they literally put badges and if
you understand any much software
development like you have to think about
this like tick tock spent millions of
dollars just to put that little like
button that says you reply to a comment
um so you can just see like the platform
will love you if you do that the second
thing is I do this okay this is one of
my secrets I'm only gonna give it to
think media podcasts okay so here it is
you need to like make your audience like
part of the story so I do this thing
where I do part 1 part 2 part 3 and I'm
not talking about that look in a YouTube
video where you're like part 1 is like
all about this topic and then part 2 is
gonna be about another one like no I'm
talking about like you want to leave
them on a cliffhanger so like what I
would always do
is especially on my tic TOCs when i'm
like trying new stuff like i quite
popular for trying to boat layout so
instead of being like you know i could
just try it out on camera i said hey
guys like this video part 2 part part 2
the audience likes it and they're
commenting with me like oh my god I'm so
excited you should try this so like what
happens is the narrative is building up
with the audience and that's one of my
been working really well because Tech
Talk is you know indoor will promote
stuff that has more likes and stuff so
you really get to do two things at once
kill two birds with one stone and you
get people part of the narrative and
that's true engagement yeah and building
any type of fan loyalty is always
becomes platform agnostic like the
reason that Viners were able to make it
on YouTube is because they built a fan
base right the reason that youtubers are
able to make it on other platforms is
because they're building actual equity
with their fans and turning a fan into a
customer takes time it's not gonna
happen overnight but you're going deeper
and deeper with your audience on
tic-tock and that is in turn going to
allow for you to grow on other platforms
grow your business grow your software
when you promote something new they're
all in right because you've given them
some personal attention yeah one thing
to add to that one piece of statistic
you're gonna be mind-blowing to hear
this I just got this word that
apparently 60% of tik-tok users like
people who download tik-tok that is
their only social media Wow which
basically means like they don't have
like kids that are maybe like I'm
talking like under 13 but like they
don't have its you know they don't even
have YouTube tik-tok is their only media
if you're not there for the new
generation in 5-10 years your product
will be obsolete so I really do think
like that piece of data was like super
look like my modeling to me yeah wow
that is that's just making me think
about what we're doing here at think
media what we're doing on the things
marketing podcast and how we can reach
that next generation with the tools that
they're gonna need right they're the
next generation of creators they're the
next generation of entrepreneurs and
while we love serving the audience that
we have here on YouTube and on the
podcast really it's about who's going to
be your customer in the future so that
is those are some really awesome tips
that you gave us right there Jade and
this is just the beginning right we have
grow with video live coming in sept
you're gonna be there speaking all about
YouTube and about Instagram and about
tik-tok and how you've been able to
amass over 10 million views on YouTube
and Instagram that's mind-blowing I'm so
excited to hear more about what that
process looked like for you but Jane
where can people find you if they want
to connect with you before we go to
growth video live you guys there's two
things you guys can reach me on my
Instagram it's Jade I'm a long sigh I
know my last name is long but hopefully
Heather you got in the show notes yes of
course and you guys I've been really
obsessed with this like again engagement
so you can find me on tech talk but you
guys can also text my phone number it's
66 three one seven six eight six three
hopefully it's in the show notes too but
text me anytime it's my personal cell
where we can chat I said broadcast LED
marketing and if you want to know more
about tik-tok I would also follow me
there for sure wow that was some great
tick-tock information from Jade yeah man
I love Jade so much I mean really
inspiring everything that she's doing
and I just think man at 18 I was not
running businesses and like able to
communicate noon all this stuff I mean
she's super inspiring but even more than
that I think it's cool to keep a pulse
on these trending platforms you know of
course
tick tock is brand new and kind of
vulnerable like we don't know where it's
gonna go
but even as Jada said we've had some
people in our video ranking Academy that
have taken action on tick tock they've
seen some post blowing up going viral
but it's led to awareness back to their
YouTube channel which is much more of a
solid ground pillar place of content and
so I'm so pumped about what we just
learned from Jade and that she's coming
to grow a video live 2020 as one of our
speakers yeah I can't wait for gross
video live it's happening in September
and if you want to see some of the
current deals and specials we have right
now for the think marketing community
you can go to grow with video live.com
and also remember we are action takers
here at the think marketing podcast and
so take a moment to write down a next
step maybe it was inspired by this
episode directly or maybe you're just
being reminded right now man I gotta
shoot that video I got a press record I
got to plan those videos out I need to
work on that business development
opportunity whatever it is what gets
scheduled gets done and
plan on paper so write down your next
action step yeah and while you're doing
that we want to shout out one of the
think marketing listeners you left a
review on the podcast and so Hugh we
want to say thank you for your review
and here's what he said he says as a
filmmaker I really loved listening to
the topics on this podcast I know I'm a
good I'm no I'm good at video production
but I've always struggled with the more
business-minded side of everything it's
so needed to have that healthy balance
of being a creative creator but also
being able to communicate and operate in
the business world
thanks guys keep it up well thanks you
for leaving that review and if you would
like to leave a review and be
spotlighted here on the think marketing
podcast you can do that on Apple iTunes
and we would love to read your review
next week absolutely and remember we're
giving away two tickets to grow a video
live picking out one of the reviews why
we've been launching to think marketing
show it's been fun right and we are just
getting started so if you want to learn
how you can win two tickets to grow a
video live here in Las Vegas just go to
think marketing show com yeah and we are
so grateful for you being a part of the
think marketing community and we would
love for you to see us every single week
you can do that by subscribing on
youtube if you're watching us or you can
subscribe wherever you're listening to
this podcast thanks so much for
listening and we'll catch you in the
next episode
[Music]